خيري تفضل
محمد نعم هذه الاحياء الضيقه هنا في مخيم
عسكر القديم في مدينه نابلس حوصرت لعده
ساعات صباح هذا اليوم من قبل قوات
اسرائيليه كبيره اقتحمت في الحقيقه هذا
المخيم وحاصرت هذه الاحياء وكذلك اقتحمت
هذه القوات ايضا مخيم بلاطه القريب من هنا
دارت اشتباكات هنا في هذه الاحياء الضيقه
جدا كما تشاهدونها بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والشبان
الفلسطينيين خلال هذه الاشتباكات اطلق
الجيش الاسرائيلي الرصاص الحي على
الفلسطينيين ما ادى الى اصابه اربعه منهم
بجروح نقلوا على اثرها الى المستشفى هذا
المنزل الذي نحن على وشك الدخول اليه هو
منزل الاسير احمد بنات وهو الذي اسرته
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم هذا
الاسير نشير الى انه كان قد نجى من محاوله
اغتيال قبل عده اسابيع في شارع عمان وفي
شارع بلاطه من خلال طائره مسيره
اسرائيليه لكنه بقي مطاردا
ولذلك حاصرت القوات الاسرائيليه منزله
ومنزل العائله كما تشاهدون اثار التخريب
واثار الحرائق التي اشعلها الجنود
الاسرائيليون هنا في المنزل لم يتركوا فيه
زاويه الا وخربوها ودمروها
واحرقوها قال لي سكان المنزل وعائله
الاسير ان هذا الاحراق وهذا التدمير كانت
الغايه منه فقط معاقبه جميع افراد
العائله قبل اعتقال الاسير احمد بنات
وكذلك يشار الى ان قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعتدت على سكان هذا المنزل رجالا ونساء
وخاصه والد الشاب الاسير ونكلت بهم بعنف
شديد قبل ان تضغط على الاسير من اجل تفسير
تسليم نفسه عفوا بعدما اتخذت من والده لا
ادري اذا كانت لديك فرصه محمد اذا كانت
لديك فرصه ان تتحدث الى احد افراد الاسره
ربما لنسمع منه
مباشره نعم نعم سنتحدث الى الى والد اسير
يمكنكم مشاهده حجم الدمار الذي احدثه
الجنود الاسرائيليون هنا في المنزل من ثم
احرقو يعني
هم نعم معنا والد والد الاسير احمد بنات
عمر احمد عثمان بنات والد احمد والد ياسين
والد جهاد ثلاثه ا اخبرتني انهم يعني
اعتدوا عليك بشده وعد خلوك در بشري تقريبا
تحقيق كان ميداني معي انا الابو حوالي
اكثر من ساعه عن ابني احمد وانا ما بعرف
عنه شي شاب مطلوب ما بعرف وين بروح ولا
وين بيجي شو شكل الاعتداء عليك و الاعتداء
بالضرب بالبوار
بال بالبوار اللي حاملين يعني بلشوا في
حشوني حشوني بالغرفه هي وبلشوا في ضرب لما
صاروا العيال الصوط نزلوني حشرني برا
قالوا لي معك خمس دقائق ابنك موجود بالبيت
اللي مجاور هون بجنب بس اشرح لنا كيف
عملوك درع بشري عشان انت تجبره ويسلم حاله
بس وصف لنا هذا المشهد يعني انا ما انا ما
كنت درع بشري لهم هم ع في بالطيران حددوا
موقعه وقالوا لي بدنا نكسف البيت هذا هو
موجود في داخل البيت هذا بتخش بطوله ما
بنكسف ما معك خمس دقائق فخشيت اقنعت ابني
انه يسلم حاله بدهم يصفوا البيت ابني ما
بده يسلم حاله بس وافق لتسليم نفسه في
طفله وفي مراه موجوده معه بالبيت عشان هيك
سلم نفسه اذا اذا كما شاهدتم هي اعتداءات
مستمره ليس فقط على الاسرى والمطاردين
الفلسطينيين كما تصفهم قوات الاحتلال انما
على عائلات هؤلاء الاسرى وكذلك ما تشهده
منازل تخريب وتدمير واحراق واضح يعني هذه
الممارسات اذا المعتاده من جانب قوات
الاحتلال اشكرك محمد خيري من مخيم
عسكر في نابلس شكرا جزيلا لك